وكانت القناه الثالث عش الاسرائيليه نقلت
عن مسؤول اسرائيلي ان اسرائيل لم تتلقى
بعد ردا من حماس بشان صفقه التبادل واضاف
انه يتوقع ان يصل الرد من قطر في غضون
ساعات واضاف كذلك ان هناك تفاؤلا بشان
امكانيه تحريك الصفقه وقال رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو ان حكومته
تبذل كل الجهود لاعاده الاسرى المحتجزين
واشار خ خلال لقائه بممثلين عن عائلاتهم
الى انه كلما تمت المحافظه على سريه
الجهود كبرت فرصه النجاح ومن جانبه اعرب
زعيم المعارضه في اسرائيل يا اير لابيد عن
استعداده للانضمام للحكومه وذلك في سبيل
الافراج عن الاسرى وكان منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في مجلس الامن القومي جون
كيربي اكد ان الرئيس بايدن يعمل شخصيا على
صفقه وان واشنطن تبحث مع اسرائيل قطر سبل
وقف لاطلاق النار وادخال المساعدات وخفض
التصعيد